alors quand on dit on a eu paris
critique d'art dont l'une est noire
hector obalk insiste warhol n'est pas un
grand artiste etc tort ou à raison aux
balles qu'avec ou sans mention
randy est un génie ou un rôle c'est du
vol ta gueule j'écoute [ __ ] de monde
l airbag bonsoir alors après cannes
roland garros en même temps les rolling
stones avant les vacances et une
focalisation médiatique énorme sur andy
warhol et toi mieux de tout ça tu arrivé
qu'un bon cachet oublié qui dit andy
warhol n'est pas un grand artiste
[Musique]
guy andy warhol est un grand
publicitaire la pub c'est pas du grand
art donc warhol n'est pas un grand
artiste ça c'est le raisonnement de base
du vivre
cqfd alors tu expliques que andy warhol
est un grand publicitaire pour commencer
et tu pars du concept chevaux quand même
dit qu'il choisit ses sujets comme
finalement choisi des concepts dans la
pub quoi ah bah oui parce que bon comme
marlboro je prends parce que c'est pas
d'école comme à leurs fins ces westerns
afin d'entériner un jeu faut même il
faut même se dire que je vais récupérer
ouais j'ai récupéré il ya une pub pour
ricard l'a dernièrement c'est juste
après le grand plus pour ce qui est des
hommes soudainement et dans l'ouest dont
il faut quand même savoir que la musique
de marlborough qui est connu comme les
amoureux c'est la musique de sept
mercenaires et dans le cadre de la rolls
qu'est ce que c'est
qui récupère comme l'avait classé le
premier point ans on étudie son style
pictural c'est la direction artistique
bah oui parce que si la photo est pas de
lui si le cadre est le plus ouvert
possible s'est dit surpris ils
s'éclatent sur les couleurs alors il
fait c'est vrai il fait des trucs plus
ou moins bien on réussit aux couleurs et
mais quoi qu au début non au début ils
gardent les couleurs berceau ainsi
surprise ou presque on en fait une
partie dans dix ans tu comprends c'est
génial il a fait de campbell soup la
joconde lycée
je voulais sortir lacombe si elles
datent de 98 mais c'est dingue c'est ce
que je veux dire c'est que ça c'est un
packaging magnifique 98 1890 du 19e
siècle
bon c'est déjà un must il arrive en cinq
ans 62 et puis tant fait ils t'ont fait
saillant la joconde du ciel je dis non
dit le mec qui a fait ça est déjà plus
fort toujours le plan publicitaire tu
dis son discours c'est des slogans c'est
une suite de slogan fait c'est pas un
discours sur la peinture
non je suis très fort dans son cas c'est
qu'il a quatre ou cinq slogans parmi
lesquels vont jouer en citer un parce
qu'ils libèrent connus mais les trains
il est très bon à la vérité ce très bon
son histoire de quel plus beau à paris
ces bacchanales séquelles du bois
florence masque ap buenos aires scandale
pékin et moscou encore rien de beau
c'est très bon surtout parce que c'est
faux maintenant mais c'est pas grave il
était mort et ce qui est fort dans son
affaire c'est que n'importe quelle
phrase de warhol j'aime l'ennui je
voudrais être une machine un truc sur
mcdonald's s'applique à n'importe quel
tableau et donc savoir jeudi on peut
légende et n'importe quelle photo
choisie par warhol mise en scène par dix
ont dirigé artistiquement par voir le
directeur artistique et légendées par
andy warhol rédacteurs pendant la pub et
sat et ça marche très bien quand tu
démontres assez clairement que warhol
est un grand publicitaire
mais qu'est ce qui te fait dire que la
pub c'est pas de là je me souviens des
déclarations de jacques blanc qui disait
dans le globe
la pub j'adore ces deux là
il faut pas le dire enfin c'est zéro son
nez ça que je suis content penser ça
nous encore très loin parce que toute
cette idéologie du du tout et de large
je suis contre et je pense que ce point
de vue là adieu ma cible c'est autant
les publicitaires qui cependant pour les
artistes c'est le problème de goutelas
quand il a fait son expulsion marseille
qui était la risée total alors que
c'était bien quand il faisait quand tu
veux excuser mais et c'est le même site
que j'ai sur l'art contemporain dit
avant gardiste dans les deux cas ils
sont persuadés que que c'est l'idée qui
compte et que le reste n'a pas
d'importance on peut on laisser à
d'autres secteurs
tous y sont ils pensent tous que l'idée
du savoir faire et des siècles et non je
suis pas d'accord je suis pour l'art
moderne contre la faim en pâtira pas
avec le dos de la cuillère tu dis les
tables de warhol cd mauvaise photocopie
couleur exposé dans une maison des
jeunes et de la culture c'est sérieux
non non ça veut dire que dans faut être
juste fait juste quand ça se produit
quand s'est produit le 17 janvier a
jusque là si ce n'est pas parce qu'on
s'est reproduit dans un catalogue en
appréciant que c'est assez fort il y en
a qui se sont succédé transcender c'est
à dire que le grain de la photographie
surtout chez liszt et l'heure où il a
parfaitement réussi son coup dans la
photographie d'un presque désert de
grandes pointures à son affaire et puis
et puis puisqu'il tue moi c'est quand
j'ai dû alors je suis allé parce qu'une
transition là c'est pas d'autres qu'il a
fait c'est le moment qu'il a fait un
américain non je suis allé à düsseldorf
le droit chemin et c'est géant
c'est gênant c'est gênant ce que parce
que des photos d'accidents de voiture
fait valoir le visant
noir et blanc sur un fond or alive dans
les médias pour que ça a l'air un peu
chic dans tout ça mais ça fait vraiment
ça fait mauvais ce loto
alors tu dois en plus ils fatiguent pas
vraiment parce que faire un symbole avec
campbell soup qui est un must de l'été
déjà l'aise avec marie maniche et marina
qui est bénéfique voilà donc toi tu dis
c'est pas de l'art c'est l'art du vol
bon c'est pas de la cdf est facile c'est
un effet qu'ils sont roms qui sont
téléphonés franchement c'est vrai que
c'est assez vrai qu'une intensité dans
des accidents de voiture et dans les les
chaises électriques
mais bon elle y était déjà quoi merde
c'est électrique alors il ça je veux pas
voir sa cote est l'archétype même hyper
facile parce que moindrot finalement
c'est la photo de cordes man qu'il a
repris qui est excellent donc c'est le
talent de monroe c'est le talent de
cordemais et puis c'est la ceiba
directeur artistique les gens
comprennent bien ce que je veux dire
quand et d'essai quand un tableau de
magritte et d'un grain de faire la mise
en page
pour un livre de philo alors que tu vas
le cadre est plus ou moins bien tu vas
être suffisamment habile dans le choix
et où il ya un art du choix mais au fond
ou warhol tu lèves pour lui consacre un
volet sympathique il faut on a dit des
conneries sur lui sur on a voulu exagéré
et c'est toujours des mauvais simplement
quand on veut descendre quelqu'un qui
ont commencé à quadriller tout bon on a
voulu absolument dire qu'ils sont
entourés mec qu'il avait un plaisir
pervers à les voir mourir voir a laissé
des amourettes savoir c'est déconne mais
à mon avis c'est des conneries non c'est
un type sympathique hyper honnête tout
ce qu'il veut c'est gagner de l'argent
tout ce qui y est dit que la sérigraphie
c'est vachement bien parce qu'elle est
fatiguée qu'un autre à sa place
la raison et il dit surtout sa plus
grande phrase qui est toujours mais
entendu de 10 et vous savez pour
comprendre tout ça andy warhol vous
n'avez qu'à regarder la surface de ses
pattes de mes peintures la surface de
mes films la surface de moi et rien
derrière
et je suis d'accord derrière l'étudient
qui il vit sa vie comme une campagne de
pub et c'est vrai que ce que tu racontes
en tout cas c'est quand il arriva à new
york en arrivant de pittsburgh en 49
il a déjà tout trouvé parce qu'il fait
des reproductions il envoie les petit
portfolio à tout le monde pour se faire
connaître enfin c'est vrai enfin là il
faut être un peu méchant parce que
paraît il faut le dire dans les années
50 quand il vient il n'est pas pris
comme comme directeur artistique sert
comme coloriste de quelque chose comme
concepteur il est prêt comme
illustrateur sert comme un artiste
commerce à quand un artiste qui est là
dont se servent les directeurs et
l'utilisateur joujou le corps de man qui
veulent qui va faire auquel il va faire
jouer le rôle dans les années 60
et quand illustrateur il fait moi je dit
exprimant façon bréard enfin ce sombre
et plutôt pour une fois ce sont des
trucs et son vrai truc c'est quoi cdi
dit à la cocteau cdc des trucs à la bird
les super maniéré [ __ ] tout ça avant et
c'est zéro et comme il sait que c'est
zéro ça c'est du chant c'est pareil
l'arrêtent
c'est une illustration comme du chant
arrête sa peinture et 1 913 et se dit
non il faut un gros coup il faut un gros
coup il faut parce que comme je dis là
horreur comme tous ces mécanismes
horreur d'être jugé tout le truc c'est
la fuite du
je manque un syndrome raison d'un
certain art de l'idée de duchamp a pu
rennes klein etc
c'est quoi faire pour ne pas être jugé
pour ce que j'ai fait et on va montrer
campbell soup des trucs très fort de
gros mythe marilyn monroe déchets
électriques est comme ça il est sûr que
sa main qu'il faut des volutes à la
cocteau on la verra jamais on pourra
jamais à juger et on dirait jamais c'est
ratissent le faible ne pas être un
artiste plutôt père prince 12.1 traîne
artistes faible c'est quand même le
ventre est ce que tu crois que ce
bouquin autant de succès que les
mouvements de mode expliquer aux parents
le warhol ouais non plus combien
allez-vous en mode 170 ha ouais je
comprends édition de poche entre est
toujours sonné j'ai commandé 100 des
chers alors il ya un bouquin tu devais
faire ce qui s'appelait la culture
classique expliqué aux jeunes après les
mouvements de prix appliquées aux
parents c'est la panique
ce qui au japon paris pourrait tuer
jamais fait basculer avant non non c'est
vrai c'est vrai on te fait un bouquin
avec ton copain voir on s'appelle ma vie
or c'est assez drôle c'est 120 double
page blanche
les qui ont écrit comme ça sur les
sujets l'amour la famille la maison
l'argent on remplit ont rempli les cas
ces sorties pour les cadeaux de fin
d'année fin 89 et pour 190 francs dont l
auteur le héros le lecteur électeurs
dans celle du sénat noël non plus ce
problème c'est qu'on peut pas le finir
ce bouquin se dire que c'est vous n'en
savez si proches qu'ils écrivent la
dernière page bientôt s'il fait semblant
sont à double battant puisque tu écriras
tout à l'heure en rentrant chez toi /
aujourd'hui dans ma vie à la question
serait plutôt est ce que j'avais
sélectionné à quai on a parlé ensemble
les corrections de ne rien rater de
finale andy tube abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus